out of all the health problems you can
get a stroke could be probably one of
the most devastating conditions today
we're talking about how to avoid strokes
specifically a silent stroke what is a
silent stroke it's a minor stroke that
has no symptoms but does cause the
damage so there's certain parts of the
brain that aren't involved in speech or
motor control and so if you have a
stroke in those areas you're not going
to notice the normal paralysis on one
side or the slurred speech you may
notice a little bit of loss of memory
but no major symptoms and these silent
strokes are very very common in fact 14
times more common than a big stroke and
if you do research on strokes it lists
the risk factors right and says diabetes
high blood pressure cholesterol obesity
atrial fibrillation which is the
dysfunction of the rhythm of the heart
and then metabolic syndrome and sleep
apnea what do all these problems have in
common well these are all symptoms of
high insulin okay so let's talk about
the things that you can do right now to
prevent clotting and a stroke okay
number one DHA and EPA what are those
these are two very special types of
fatty acids they're omega-3 fatty acids
they're in fatty fish especially salmon
and halibut and sardines
cod liver oil and you can also get DHA
from algae but you need something with
both of these right here the interesting
thing about these healthy fats is that
your brain thrives on them they're
involved in certain genes that not only
build the structure of the brain but the
function of the brain and the repair of
brain damage there anti-inflammatory as
well so this is very very important in
preventing or avoiding strokes number
two garlic there's a certain vital
nutrient in garlic that the drug
companies right now are trying to
isolate to use is an anti clotting drug
well why not just consume garlic it's a
great blood thinner without any side
effects now there are certain
medications that
we're taking that our anti-clotting like
committin for example which blocked by
them k but there's not only side effects
but it really restricts your eating
because you can't consume leafy greens
anymore you have to consume foods very
low in vitamin K and if you're on
Cummington I put a link down below of
what diet you should be on in what
vegetables you can consume exercise
vital to increase circulation not just
in your brain but in the heart as well
now there's also this thing called
exogenous ketones I don't recommend
exogenous ketones for the average person
because you yourself can make your own
ketones okay but there's two situations
in which I would recommend exogenous
ketones and I'm talking about ketones
salts there is another version of
ketones that you can get called ketones
esters specifically for athletes that
are competing and they need some more
energy or performance when they're
working out very very expensive
the salts are a lot less expensive they
don't work as well when you have a
stroke or you have Alzheimer's the brain
cells are damaged so you're gonna have
great difficulty and having glucose
penetrate the cells to feed the cells so
the common denominator for dementia is
the cell can't get fuel anymore so it
can't work anymore the good thing is
ketones can bypass the damaged tissue
not just in the brain but to the heart
as well and you can feed the damaged
cell directly so it can get the fuel and
start thriving your brain loves ketones
if given the choice it will absorb
ketones more than glucose so as far as
taking ketones if you have a damaged
brain Alzheimer's or memory problems or
dementia or even a damaged heart I would
recommend taking this because that will
actually help feed those tissues and the
other situation is if you're competing
with some type of exercise and you need
some more energy when you're exercising
I would recommend this number five
vitamin E very very important to help
thin the blood and the clots but make
sure the version about a mini that you
take is not a synthetic version you want
something that we
all the natural decoff roles and the
toget Reno's together okay it's a whole
complex it can really help decrease the
risk and of course the most important
thing is get on healthy keto and in a
minute fasting because what's going to
happen is that you're going to decrease
your risk of stroke and you're going to
get the real root cause of all of these
right here which is high insulin and
insulin resistance because keto NIF
improves insulin resistance and it
lowers in some all right thanks for
watching so if you want to get notified
with all my content click the
notification bell next to subscribed